Reggie Richardson and his identical twin brother Ronnie went to grade school and high school together. They were roommates in college and track stars together. They trained as educators together, taught fourth grade classes side by side, were assistant principals together, and finally, this fall, achieved something they'd dreamed of together since they were teenagers-- they became co-principals of a school, Claremont Middle School in Oakland, California.
雷吉·理查森和他的同卵双胞胎兄弟罗尼一起上小学和高中。大学期间他们是室友，也是学校田径队的明星。他们一起接受教育培训，并排执教四年级课程，一起担任副校长，最后，在今年秋天，他们实现了自少年时代起就共同梦想的目标——他们成为了加利福尼亚州奥克兰克莱蒙特中学的联合校长。
And what's that like? Well, one recent morning, I was talking to Reggie in his office when Ms. Champion, the administrative assistant, called on the walkie-talkie.
那是什么样的感觉呢？最近一个早晨，我正在雷吉的办公室与他交谈，行政助理钱皮恩女士通过对讲机叫他。
This is Mr. Richardson.
我是理查森先生。
I have Orion's mom on the phone, and she says it's urgent.
奥里昂的妈妈在电话上，她说情况很紧急。
Is she on the line now?
她现在在通话中吗？
Yes.
是的。
Do you want to transfer me?
你要转接给我吗？
OK, which Mr. Richardson is this?
好的，请问是哪位理查森先生？
Reggie Richardson.
雷吉·理查森。
OK, thanks.
好的，谢谢。
Copy that.
收到。
Turns out to be an incredibly handy thing, having your identical twin as your co-principal. They handle things the same. They know how each other thinks. They look the same. When kids arrive in the morning or leave in the afternoon, they both wander around the grounds. And there's this feeling of omnipresence. Here's Reggie's brother, Ronnie.
事实证明，拥有一个和你一模一样的双胞胎兄弟作为联合校长是非常方便的事情。他们处理事情的方式相同。他们了解对方的想法。他们长得一模一样。当孩子们早上到达或下午离开时，他们两人都会在校园里走动。于是便产生了一种无处不在的感觉。这是雷吉的兄弟，罗尼。
What's powerful about having two of us is that even the teachers and the students are like, wow, he's everywhere. I turn this corner, he's there. I turn this corner, he's there.
我们两个人一起工作最厉害的地方在于，连老师和学生都会感叹，哇，他无处不在。我转过这个拐角，他在那里。我转过那个拐角，他也在那里。
When I first came, I didn't know they were twins, and I needed help finding my classes. So I seen one by the stairs, and then I walked down the hallway and I seen another one. Like, they were at too places at the same time, and I thought it was one person. And I was like, what?
我刚来的时候，不知道他们是双胞胎，我需要帮助来找教室。我在楼梯旁看到了一个，然后我走到走廊里又看到了另一个。就像是他们同时出现在两个地方，我还以为是一个人。当时我就想，什么情况？
To afford two principals, the school has no assistant principal. And mostly, the two brothers just pass things off, perfect surrogates for each other. Ever wish you had a second you to help you with your kids or your job at work? That is every day for these guys.
为了能负担得起两名校长，学校没有副校长。大多数时候，两兄弟只是互相交接任务，互为完美的替身。有没有想过你希望有第二个自己来帮你照顾孩子或处理工作？对这些人来说，这就是日常。
Something comes up for Ronnie and he can't meet with a parent, he just tells Reggie to do it. The morning I was there, a group of parents and kids who'd be coming to Claremont next year was getting a tour. Ronnie was the one who was supposed to lead it. Which he did, at first.
如果罗尼有事无法会见家长，他就会告诉雷吉去处理。我在那里的那天早晨，一群明年即将进入克莱蒙特中学的家长和孩子们正在参观学校。罗尼本应是带队的那个人。起初他确实这么做了。
Good morning, beautiful scholars.
早上好，美丽的学者们。
Good morning.
早上好。
His brother Reggie stopped into the library where the tour was starting, said a few words. The plan was that his participation was going to be brief. But then when the bell rang, Ronnie, the one who's supposed to be leading the tour, stepped into the hallway to monitor the change of classes, which these guys do all day long.
他的兄弟雷吉顺道去了参观开始的图书馆，说了几句开场白。原本计划他的参与会很简短。但当铃声响起时，本应带队的罗尼走到了走廊里去监管课间变动，这是他们整天都在做的事情。
James? James. James. Can you please take your beanie off, son? Thank you.
詹姆斯？詹姆斯。詹姆斯。能请你摘掉毛线帽吗，孩子？谢谢。
And he stayed out there. Back in the library, stuck with the tour group now, his brother Reggie vamped.
然后他就留在那里了。回到图书馆，被参观团困住的他的兄弟雷吉只能即兴发挥。
Um, however in the interim, I-- Mr. Richardson stepped out. You know, we get real busy, so he should be back. But I'm going to split you in groups. If we have to do a large group, we will do so. But he should be back momentarily.
嗯，不过在此期间，我……理查森先生出去了。你知道，我们真的很忙，所以他应该会回来。但我打算把你们分成小组。如果我们必须进行大组参观，我们也会这样做。但他应该很快就会回来。
When Ronnie returned, the two continued the tour together for a while, and then Reggie ditched out, leaving Ronnie. This swapping tasks back and forth happens all day long between them. And since they arrived at Claremont at the beginning of this school year, everybody-- kids, parents, teachers-- all say they have made a huge difference.
当罗尼回来后，两人一起继续带领参观了一会儿，然后雷吉就溜走了，留下了罗尼。这种任务来回切换在他们之间整天都在发生。自从他们今年学年初来到克莱蒙特以来，每个人——孩子、家长、老师——都说他们带来了巨大的改变。
Claremont went through several principals last year, and it was chaotic. Kids were roaming the halls when they were supposed to be in class. It was such a mess, teachers say, that it drove the kids' standardized test scores down. Now it's orderly, thanks to the Richardsons.
克莱蒙特去年换了好几任校长，学校一片混乱。孩子们本该在教室上课却在走廊里游荡。老师们说，情况糟糕到导致孩子们的标准化考试成绩下滑。现在多亏了理查森兄弟，学校变得井井有条。
And among the students who they've taken a special interest in are a pair of twins from the seventh grade, Faith and Hope, who've been to the principal's office many, many times since Hope transferred into the school this fall. Faith had attended here last year. Here is how Hope sees things. She's new in school, and the person she knows best doesn't want her nearby.
在他们特别关注的学生中，有一对七年级的双胞胎，菲斯和霍普。自今年秋天霍普转学到这所学校以来，她们已经多次被叫到校长办公室。菲斯去年就在这里读书了。以下是霍普看待事情的方式。她在学校里是新人，而她最了解的那个人却不想让她靠近。
Well, we use to share classes, but she got hers switched, so we don't share no classes now.
嗯，我们过去共用课程，但她把课换了，所以我们现在没有共用的课了。
She got hers switched so you guys wouldn't be in all your classes together?
她把课换了，这样你们就不会所有课都在一起了？
She doesn't like to, like, really hang out with me. But yeah, she got them switched to her best friend's classes.
她不喜欢和我待在一起。但是的，她把课程换成了她闺蜜的课。
What'd you think of that?
你对此怎么看？
Uh, I'm used to it.
呃，我已经习惯了。
They got along when they were little, she says, but now they're teenagers, and it's different.
她说，她们小时候相处得很好，但现在她们是青少年了，情况变了。
So how did she start to act?
那么她开始有什么表现？
Like more-- meaner. And, like, teenager-y, selfish. That's why-- OK, we get along at home, but not at school. She likes to keep her space.
变得更……更刻薄了。而且，像青少年一样，自私。这就是为什么——好吧，我们在家里相处得来，但在学校不行。她喜欢保持自己的空间。
Treated like that, a person can act up, try to get the other person's attention. Which Hope does. It's not so effective.
受到这种对待，一个人可能会闹脾气，试图引起对方的注意。这就是霍普的做法。但这并不奏效。
I'm always mad at her.
我总是对她很生气。
Here's Faith, her sister.
这是她的姐姐菲斯。
She steal my clothes. She's like an instigator. When somebody's about to fight, she runs back and forth saying stuff.
她偷我的衣服。她是个煽风点火的人。当有人要打架时，她就在旁边来回跑，说三道四。
And she takes jokes too far. And then she acts the fool everywhere she goes. Like she always bring attention to herself. I don't like that much attention, so.
而且她开玩笑开得太过分了。无论走到哪里都表现得像个傻瓜。就像她总是把注意力吸引到自己身上。我不喜欢那么多关注，所以。
And everybody thinks of us as one. Like everything she do, they say, why y'all do that? They even think that it's me. And she's evil.
每个人都把我们看作一个人。就像她做的一切，他们会说，你们为什么要那样做？他们甚至认为那是我。而她很邪恶。
Like I said, she has anger issues. She's the meaner one. Everybody says it.
就像我说的那样，她有愤怒管理问题。她是更刻薄的那一个。每个人都这么说。
The troubles between these 13-year-old twins definitely got the attention of the 36-year-old twins over in the principal's office.
这两位13岁双胞胎之间的麻烦，绝对引起了校长办公室里那两位36岁双胞胎的注意。
Because we kind of get offended. We got a little offended when they were-- we took it personal. It's something about twins that really, because we are twins, when we see siblings having issues and disrespecting each other in public, we take it a little bit more personal.
因为我们有点被冒犯了。当她们那样做时，我们感到有点被冒犯……我们把它个人化了。关于双胞胎有一些特殊之处，因为我们本身就是双胞胎，当我们看到亲姐妹之间有矛盾并在公开场合互相不尊重时，我们会感到更个人化一些。
Reggie says that for a while, the twin girls were in their office constantly with both brothers.
雷吉说，有一段时间，这对双胞胎女孩总是和两兄弟一起待在办公室里。
And we were really talking to them about it. And Ronnie started it. Twin code. How to respect each other as sisters. Because when we hear, like, shut up. No, you shut up. No, you're ugly. No, you're ugly. We're like, whoa, no. That's totally against twin code. Let's talk about this. Calm down, girls.
我们真的在和她们谈论这件事。罗尼发起了对话。双胞胎守则。如何作为姐妹互相尊重。因为当我们听到像“闭嘴。不，你闭嘴。不，你真丑。不，你才丑”这样的对话时，我们会觉得，哇，不。这完全违背了双胞胎守则。让我们谈谈这个。冷静点，女孩们。
He said that we have a gift.
他说我们拥有一种天赋。
This is Faith.
这是菲斯。
Because not everybody gets to be a twin. And that we're breaking twin code by doing this stuff to each other.
因为不是每个人都有机会成为双胞胎。而且我们通过这样对待彼此来打破双胞胎守则。
Wait, what's the twin code?
等等，什么是双胞胎守则？
I don't know.
我不知道。
And then we talked about, you come from greatness. You're queens and kings.
然后我们谈到了，你们出身高贵。你们是女王和国王。
He would just call us kings and queens, something, something. I wasn't really listening.
他只会叫我们国王和女王，之类的。我当时没怎么听。
I appreciate that they trying to help. But I don't like her.
我很感激他们试图提供帮助。但我就是不喜欢她。
So they said that we only have each other and all that, so we should stick together. Like, I try to do that with my sister, but she doesn't really like that. Like, I always try to give her hugs and say hi and stuff, but she doesn't like that. She just doesn't want to be my friend, so I just let it slide.
所以他们说我们只有彼此等等，所以我们应该团结一致。就像，我试图和我姐姐那样做，但她并不真的喜欢那样。比如，我总是想给她拥抱，说你好之类的，但她不喜欢。她只是不想和我做朋友，所以我只好顺其自然。
That was Hope. Here's Faith.
那是霍普。这是菲斯。
No, I just think that it's not that easy, 'cause I gotta go to school with her and I gotta go home with her. I gotta walk home with her. I gotta see her when I wake up, when I go to sleep. And I don't like her.
不，我只是认为这没那么简单，因为我得和她一起上学，还得和她一起回家。我得和她一起走路回家。我醒来时要见到她，睡觉时也要见到她。而且我不喜欢她。
Oh, that's some improvement.
噢，那真是有些进步了。
Ronnie says that a few months ago, they weren't saying "I don't like her." They were saying, "I hate her." He says that whatever they told me in the interviews, whatever they might think, they're doing better.
罗尼说，几个月前，她们说的不是“我不喜欢她”，而是“我恨她”。他说，无论她们在采访中对我说了什么，无论她们怎么想，她们都在进步。
Because they're not in the office with us every day. They're in class. They're making strides in their academics. And this is coming from their teachers, saying, wow.
因为她们没有每天都待在我们办公室了。她们在教室里。她们在学业上取得了进步。这是她们老师说的，哇。
In November, the girls even wrote them a letter thanking them for all the time and help they'd given. And for better or worse, the brothers have come to see themselves in these girls. They really want them to be closer someday. And the only question in our interview where they disagreed was-- does it matter if these two girls ever get close? First, here's Ronnie.
11月，女孩们甚至给他们写了一封信，感谢他们提供的所有时间和帮助。不管好坏，兄弟俩已经在这些女孩身上看到了自己的影子。他们真的很希望她们将来能更亲密。而我们采访中他们唯一有分歧的问题是——这两个女孩是否变得亲密重要吗？首先是罗尼。
Personally, I think it doesn't matter, as long as they're happy in their individual lives.
个人而言，我认为这并不重要，只要她们在各自的生活中感到幸福就好。
Do you think it matters?
你认为重要吗？
I think it matters that they remain-- I think they should stay close. I think that-- he's breaking twin code right now.
我认为很重要，她们应该保持……我认为她们应该保持亲密。我认为……他现在正在破坏双胞胎守则。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, but I respectfully disagree.
不，但我很抱歉地持不同意见。
Why does it's matter?
为什么这很重要？
They are each other's pulse. And whether they believe it or not yet, I see that as they get older, they're really going to need each other.
她们是彼此的脉搏。无论她们是否相信，我看到随着年龄增长，她们真的会需要彼此。
Of course, he is the one who sees a twin in his life as his pulse. And today on our show, we have people who feel this very aggressive kind of empathy, seeing their lives in somebody else's life, seeing somebody else as their surrogate. One of our stories today is about a man who did some terrible, terrible things, who, apparently, lots of people related to. The other story involves a scandal that shook Washington for decades, a scandal involving sex, power, cabinet positions, and-- here's a word I do not get to say very often-- petticoats.
当然，他是那个把生活中的双胞胎视为自己脉搏的人。今天在我们的节目中，我们邀请了那些感受到这种非常强烈的共情能力的人，在别人的生活中看到自己的影子，把别人视为自己的替身。我们今天的故事之一是关于一个做了些非常、非常可怕的事情的人，显然，很多人对此产生了共鸣。另一个故事涉及一个震撼华盛顿数十年的丑闻，一个涉及性、权力、内阁职位以及——这里有一个我很少能用到的词——衬裙的丑闻。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, "Petticoats In a Twist." So this is not the kind of Washington sex scandal that we're all used to. There's no presidential candidate, president, or congressman caught doing whatever. There's no mopey press conference with his wife by his side, blah, blah, blah.
第一幕，“衬裙风波”。所以，这并不是我们所熟悉的那种华盛顿性丑闻。没有总统候选人、总统或国会议员被抓个正着。没有他妻子站在身边的那种郁闷的新闻发布会，等等等等。
The sex scandal that we're going to talk about now was one of the first sex scandals of the American presidency. It was during Andrew Jackson's time, in the 1820s and '30s. And it affected the course of the entire country in surprisingly large ways. Sarah Koenig tells what happened during what's become known as the Petticoat Affair.
我们现在要谈论的性丑闻是美国总统史上最早的性丑闻之一。那是在安德鲁·杰克逊时代，1820年代和30年代。它以令人惊讶的程度影响了整个国家的进程。萨拉·凯尼格讲述了在后来被称为“衬裙事件”中发生的事情。
It all began with a pretty young innkeeper's daughter named Margaret O'Neale, or Peggy, as she was called. According to accounts written at the time, Peggy O'Neale was a fox. Cherry-lipped, perfectly proportioned, white skin, thick, dark, curly hair, a firm, round, chin.
这一切始于一位漂亮的年轻旅店老板的女儿，玛格丽特·奥尼尔，或者像人们叫她的那样，佩吉。根据当时的记载，佩吉·奥尼尔是个尤物。樱桃般的嘴唇，比例完美，皮肤白皙，浓密黝黑的卷发，坚实圆润的下巴。
She also had very blue eyes. That comes from other accounts.
她还有一双非常蓝的眼睛。那是来自其他记载。
That's Nancy Tomes, who teaches American history at Stony Brook University in New York.
那是南希·汤姆斯，她在纽约石溪大学教授美国历史。
She had an education. She spoke French. She danced like an angel. She played the piano. She performed in front of First Lady Dolley Madison, who was smitten with her. So clearly, she was not a yahoo. But she was crossing class lines, and that made her suspect among the ladies of Washington. And then this unfortunate business with Justin Timberlake did not help her.
她受过教育。她会说法语。她跳舞像天使一样。她会弹钢琴。她在第一夫人多莉·麦迪逊面前表演过，多莉非常迷恋她。所以很显然，她不是个乡巴佬。但她跨越了阶级界限，这使得她在华盛顿的贵妇们眼中变得可疑。而后来这段与贾斯汀·汀布莱克的倒霉事儿对她毫无帮助。
Surely his name isn't Justin Timberlake.
他的名字肯定不是贾斯汀·汀布莱克。
No. [LAUGHTER] Did I just say that? Oh, that's awful. Oh. His name was John Timberlake, not Justin. Sorry.
不。[笑声] 我刚才说了吗？哦，那太糟糕了。哦。他的名字是约翰·汀布莱克，不是贾斯汀。抱歉。
Oh, ho, ho, I have an eye trained for opportunities like this. A lonely sailor, a pretty little tavern girl, moonlit night?
哦，嘿，嘿，我有一双敏锐的眼睛，能发现这样的机会。孤独的水手，漂亮的酒店小女孩，月光下的夜晚？
That's the first time John Timberlake lays eyes on Peggy at her father's boarding house in Washington, or at least how Hollywood imagined it in the 1936 movie called The Gorgeous Hussy .
那是约翰·汀布莱克第一次在华盛顿她父亲的寄宿公寓见到佩吉，或者至少是1936年名为《绝代佳人》的好莱坞电影中想象的场景。
Will you drink?
要喝一杯吗？
Thank you.
谢谢。
To Miss O'Neale, sir, in whom I am more interested than ever.
敬奥尼尔小姐，先生，我对她比以往任何时候都更感兴趣。
Peggy marries John Timberlake very young. She's only 17. He's a purser in the Navy, which means he has to go away on long trips all the time, leaving his very young, flirtatious wife back at her father's boarding house, where all kinds of important men, especially politicians, stay while Congress is in session. She tends bar and does things women didn't usually do-- in particular, talking politics, hanging around with the guests-- while Timberlake is at sea.
佩吉很年轻就嫁给了约翰·汀布莱克。她才17岁。他是海军的一名事务长，这意味着他总是得去长途航行，把他年轻又爱调情的妻子留在他父亲的寄宿公寓里，当国会开会时，各种重要人物，尤其是政治家，都会住在这里。她在酒吧里帮忙，做着女人通常不做的事情——尤其是谈论政治，和客人们鬼混——而汀布莱克则在海上。
And while he was away, she came under the friendship of another older man, a senator from Tennessee named John Eaton. Took a big interest in the young couple. The husband had debt problems and he tried to help with them.
在他离开期间，她与另一位年长的男人，来自田纳西州的参议员约翰·伊顿建立了友谊。伊顿对这对年轻夫妇非常感兴趣。丈夫有债务问题，他试图帮忙解决。
The old let-me-help-you-with-your-debt-problems routine evidently works. Gossip starts flying that Peggy and Senator Eaton are too intimate, that they are consorting. Then Timberlake dies at sea.
“让我帮你解决债务问题”这种老套路显然很有用。流言开始四起，说佩吉和伊顿参议员过于亲密，说他们在私通。然后汀布莱克在海上死了。
He cuts his own throat, in fact. Maybe because of his debts. Maybe, rumors had it at the time, because of Peggy.
事实上，他割开了自己的喉咙。也许是因为债务。也许，当时传言是因为佩吉。
And rather than mourning her husband for the customary year or two, Peggy, the Widow Mrs. John Timberlake, becomes Mrs. John Eaton just eight months later. This is not done. It's outrageous. There's even talk that prior to the marriage, Peggy had become pregnant and had a miscarriage, or even an abortion.
佩吉，约翰·汀布莱克的遗孀，并没有像习俗那样为丈夫守寡一两年，仅仅八个月后就成为了约翰·伊顿夫人。这在当时是不合规矩的。这是令人愤慨的。甚至有传言说在结婚前，佩吉就已经怀孕并流产了，甚至做过堕胎。
The society ladies of Washington are thoroughly scandalized. Remember, women can't vote yet. They're not in politics. They're not even allowed to make public speeches.
华盛顿的社会名流们感到彻底震惊。记住，那时候女性还没有投票权。她们不参与政治。她们甚至不被允许发表公开演讲。
But that doesn't mean they're silent, especially these Washington wives, who are exposed to the workings of government. These ladies, in Jackson's time, they controlled social life, judged who was moral and who was not. That's how they influenced their powerful husbands.
但这并不意味着她们保持沉默，尤其是这些华盛顿的妻子们，她们接触到了政府的运作。在杰克逊时代，这些女士控制着社交生活，评判谁道德谁不道德。这就是她们影响她们有权势的丈夫的方式。
One of Peggy Eaton's biggest critics was Floride Calhoun, the wife of John C. Calhoun, the vice president-- so she was the vice president's wife-- from a very aristocratic South Carolina plantation aristocracy. And she was the one who first made it clear Peggy Eaton was beyond the pale. She was not going to return her call.
佩吉·伊顿最大的批评者之一是弗洛里德·卡尔霍恩，她是副总统约翰·C·卡尔霍恩的妻子——所以她是副总统夫人——来自南卡罗来纳州一个非常贵族的种植园精英家庭。她是第一个明确表示佩吉·伊顿不可救药的人。她不会回访。
That was the way you conducted war among the petticoats, is someone came to pay a call on you, and then you did not return it. And that, in the etiquette that was evolving in this era, was tantamount to a full rejection. To a full cut. And what Floride Calhoun did, the other ladies fell in line, and also cut Peggy Eaton. Refused to acknowledge her socially.
那就是你在衬裙战争中采取的方式，有人来拜访你，然后你不回访。而根据那个时代不断演变的礼仪，这相当于完全的拒绝。完全的绝交。弗洛里德·卡尔霍恩这么做了，其他女士也纷纷效仿，同样拒绝与佩吉·伊顿往来。拒绝在社交场合承认她的存在。
The job of good Christian women at this time was to improve the United States by making sure their husbands and children were model citizens, rational and virtuous. So it's not just that people disapproved of Peggy Eaton or were jealous of her, as that she was seen as a danger to the Republic. She might lead their leaders astray.
那时候优秀基督教女性的工作是通过确保丈夫和孩子成为模范公民、理性和有德行的人来改善美国。所以这不仅仅是人们不赞成佩吉·伊顿或嫉妒她，而是她被视为对共和国的一种威胁。她可能会引导她们的领袖误入歧途。
We have been forced to take this stand for the salvation of the morals of our homes.
为了拯救我们家庭的道德，我们被迫采取这一立场。
Again, Hollywood.
再次重申，这是好莱坞。
We realize that her sphere of influence is great. But we demand that she be removed from that sphere and expelled from our community.
我们意识到她的影响力很大。但我们要求她从那个领域被移除，并被逐出我们的社区。
All this was, of course, painful for Peggy Eaton. Or at least it sounded really painful for Joan Crawford, who played Peggy Eaton in The Gorgeous Hussy .
这一切，当然，对佩吉·伊顿来说是痛苦的。或者至少这对琼·克劳馥来说听起来非常痛苦，她在《绝代佳人》中饰演佩吉·伊顿。
I've humiliated myself. I've called, knowing they were at home, to be told they were not. I've ignored insults, lies, gossip. Their blue blood curdles in their veins at the very mention of the hussy.
我自取其辱。我拜访过，明知她们在家，却被告知不在。我忽视了侮辱、谎言和流言。一提到那个荡妇，她们蓝色的血液在血管里就会凝固。
Oh, they don't know anything about you, Peg.
哦，她们对你一无所知，佩吉。
Enter Andrew Jackson, freshly elected President of the United States. Peggy Eaton's personal life will soon envelope his administration. Jackson was a proud, emotional frontier politician with a famous temper. He'd been orphaned by 14 or 15. Both his parents and his two older brothers had died.
安德鲁·杰克逊登场，他刚当选为美国总统。佩吉·伊顿的个人生活很快就会笼罩他的行政班底。杰克逊是一位骄傲、情绪化、有着著名火爆脾气的边疆政治家。他14或15岁时就成了孤儿。他的父母和两个哥哥都去世了。
But he makes his way to Tennessee, becomes a successful lawyer and landowner and slaveholder-- not to mention, a military hero. And he manages all this without family connections. So he's fiercely loyal to his close friends and political allies, including John Eaton. So Eaton's trouble with the petticoats become Jackson's troubles with the petticoats.
但他前往田纳西州，成为了一名成功的律师、土地所有者和奴隶主——更不用说，他还是一位战争英雄。他在没有家庭关系支持的情况下完成了这一切。所以他对自己亲密的朋友和政治盟友极其忠诚，包括约翰·伊顿。因此，伊顿在衬裙方面的麻烦就变成了杰克逊在衬裙方面的麻烦。
Having a virtuous wife was considered part of a test of a man's character. And by that test, Eaton had failed. Now, here's where it gets interesting. By supporting Eaton, Andrew Jackson gave his enemies the ammunition to question his morality.
拥有一个贤惠的妻子被认为是考验一个男人品格的一部分。而按照这个标准，伊顿失败了。现在，有趣的地方来了。通过支持伊顿，安德鲁·杰克逊给了他的敌人质疑他道德的弹药。
Jackson wasn't going to stand for it. He'd just been through a similar battle involving his own beloved wife, Rachel. The presidential campaign of 1828 had savaged Andrew and Rachel Jackson. Anti-Jackson campaigners, supporters of John Quincy Adams, portrayed her as a backwoods pipe-smoking hayseed, with low morals to boot.
杰克逊可不会坐视不管。他刚刚经历过一场类似的涉及他心爱的妻子瑞秋的战斗。1828年的总统竞选让安德鲁和瑞秋·杰克逊身心俱疲。反杰克逊竞选者，约翰·昆西·亚当斯的拥护者，把她描绘成一个乡下吸烟斗的村姑，甚至道德低下。
Rachel had been in an unhappy marriage prior to her marrying Andrew Jackson. But it turned out that the second marriage happened before her first one was technically dissolved, unbeknownst to the Jacksons. When they figured it out, they actually remarried. Nevertheless, the anti-Jackson party launched a smear campaign. There were lengthy pamphlets, newspaper articles, saying Rachel was a bigamist.
瑞秋在嫁给安德鲁·杰克逊之前曾有一段不幸的婚姻。但事实证明，第二次婚姻是在第一次婚姻在法律上解除之前发生的，杰克逊夫妇当时并不知情。当他们弄清楚这件事时，他们实际上重新结婚了。尽管如此，反杰克逊党还是发起了抹黑运动。有大量的宣传册、报纸文章，说瑞秋是重婚者。
How do we know she is his wife?
我们怎么知道她是他妻子？
[RAUCOUS LAUGHTER]
[嘈杂的笑声]
Your Rachel ain't fit for the White House.
你的瑞秋不适合进白宫。
So Jackson was accused of being unfit for the presidency because of his relationship, this unfortunate legal muddle with Rachel Jackson. She was so distraught over the charges that she withdrew from private life.
所以杰克逊被指责不适合担任总统，因为他的人际关系，以及与瑞秋·杰克逊这桩不幸的法律糊涂账。她对这些指控感到非常痛苦，以至于退出了私人生活。
Get me my pipe, Peg. One little puff can't do no harm.
给我烟斗，佩吉。吸一口不会有坏处的。
The doctor says no, Aunt Rachel. No more pipe-smoking.
医生说不行，瑞秋姨妈。别再抽烟斗了。
This is an ailing Rachel Jackson, hunched in a rocker, wrapped in a dowdy shawl, confiding in Peggy. We don't know whether Peggy really called the soon-to-be President and First Lady "Aunt Rachel and Uncle Andy," as she does in the movie. But apparently, the Jacksons had met her at her father's boarding house and had liked her.
这是一个生病的瑞秋·杰克逊，蜷缩在摇椅里，裹着一件朴素的披肩，向佩吉倾诉。我们不知道佩吉是否真的称呼这位未来的第一夫人为“瑞秋姨妈和安迪叔叔”，就像她在电影里做的那样。但显然，杰克逊夫妇在她父亲的寄宿公寓见过她，而且很喜欢她。
Peg, these womenfolks around here are going to make it awful unpleasant for you, just like they did for me. Watch out for 'em, honey.
佩吉，这些周围的女人会让你的日子过得很不愉快，就像她们对我做的一样。小心她们，亲爱的。
She eventually had a heart attack and died soon after his election. And he always blamed the gossip for having killed his Rachel. At her funeral, he said, "May God forgive her murderers, as I know she forgave them. I never can."
她最终心脏病发作，并在他当选后不久去世了。他一直认为流言蜚语害死了他的瑞秋。在她的葬礼上，他说：“愿上帝宽恕她的谋杀者，我知道她已经宽恕了他们。我永远不能。”
Their gossip killed my Rachel, Peg. Their lying, scummy tongues killed her, just as sure as if they'd stabbed her with a knife.
她们的流言害死了我的瑞秋，佩吉。她们那撒谎的、卑鄙的舌头杀死了她，就像她们用刀刺她一样确定。
That's Lionel Barrymore, playing Andrew Jackson.
那是莱昂内尔·巴里摩尔饰演的安德鲁·杰克逊。
And I swear now, by her memory, they'll never do it again to anyone I love. Not so long as I've got one breath left in my body to stop 'em with.
我发誓，以她的记忆为誓，她们再也不能对我爱的人做同样的事了。只要我的身体里还有最后一口气来阻止她们。
So here's a man, he's in deep mourning. All the descriptions of him, he arrives as president in 1829 just broken-hearted. He wants to make Eaton, who's a very close friend of his, part of his cabinet. And he's told by the Washington insiders, don't do that. This Peggy Eaton affair, it will cause you all kinds of problems with the ladies of Washington, and their husbands as well. And Jackson is incensed.
所以这是一个男人，他正处于深重的哀悼之中。所有对他的描述都显示，他在1829年作为总统上任时心碎不已。他想让伊顿，他非常亲密的朋友，成为他内阁的一员。而他被华盛顿的内部人士告知，不要这样做。这件佩吉·伊顿丑闻，会给你和华盛顿的女士们，以及她们的丈夫们带来各种麻烦。而杰克逊被激怒了。
This really strikes chords of what had happened to his own wife. He was going to defend Peggy Eaton as he had defended his wife, as he expected any Christian gentleman to defend the honor of the woman he loves. And that, among the members of the cabinet, created a division. Did you side with the Calhouns in rejecting Peggy? Or did you side with Andrew Jackson?
这确实触及了他自己妻子经历过的事情。他要保卫佩吉·伊顿，就像他保卫自己的妻子一样，就像他期望任何一个基督徒绅士保卫他所爱女人的荣誉一样。而这在内阁成员中间造成了分裂。你是站在卡尔霍恩一边拒绝佩吉？还是站在安德鲁·杰克逊一边？
The surrogacies of this thing are dizzying. Peggy is a surrogate for Rachel. Jackson is Peggy's surrogate, fighting this fight on her behalf. And the scandal itself? Jackson sees it as a proxy for his struggles with hoity-toity enemies who are trying to beat back the progress of our country-- our young, perky, outspoken immigrant country that's a lot like Miss Peggy O'Neale.
这件事的替身关系令人目眩。佩吉是瑞秋的替身。杰克逊是佩吉的替身，为她打这场仗。而丑闻本身呢？杰克逊将其视为他与那些趾高气昂的敌人进行斗争的代理人，他们试图压制我们国家的发展——我们那个年轻、活泼、直言不讳的移民国家，就像佩吉·奥尼尔小姐一样。
Jackson, of course, does appoint Eaton his Secretary of War. And as the power couples of Washington publicly snub Peggy Eaton, now a cabinet wife, at the inauguration and at administration parties, Jackson proceeds to try to clear her reputation. He gathers testimony about her behavior, collects affidavits, argues with church leaders about it, berates his cabinet members, who won't accept her innocence.
杰克逊，当然，任命伊顿为战争部长。随着华盛顿的权力夫妇在就职典礼和行政派对上公开冷落现在的内阁夫人佩吉·伊顿，杰克逊开始试图洗清她的名誉。他收集有关她行为的证词，收集宣誓书，与教会领袖争论此事，责骂那些不接受她清白的内阁成员。
He's president of the United States, and he becomes Peggy Eaton's de facto defense counsel. He becomes obsessed. But he cannot convince his administration. Except for Secretary of State Martin Van Buren, almost no one sticks up for Peggy.
他是美国总统，他成了佩吉·伊顿事实上的辩护律师。他变得着魔了。但他无法说服他的行政班底。除了国务卿马丁·范布伦，几乎没有人支持佩吉。
By all accounts, he spent an extraordinary amount of time during his first term collecting information and haranguing people about Peggy Eaton.
据所有记录，他在第一个任期内花了极其大量的时间收集信息，并为了佩吉·伊顿向人们进行强硬说教。
Eventually, the cabinet becomes dysfunctional.
最终，内阁变得功能失调。
This led to the resignation-- in some cases, voluntary, in some cases, forced-- of almost the entire cabinet. They could not resolve this issue. Eaton resigned. Van Buren resigned.
这导致了内阁几乎全体辞职——有些是自愿的，有些是被迫的。他们无法解决这个问题。伊顿辞职了。范布伦辞职了。
I hereby ask of you and accept your resignations.
我在此要求并接受你们的辞职。
But-- but this is without precedent in the history of our country.
但是……但这在我们国家的历史上是史无前例的。
Our country is without precedent, Mr. Calhoun. But by the eternal, I'm going to have justice! Do you understand the word? Justice! Now, git.
我们的国家是史无前例的，卡尔霍恩先生。但以永恒的名义，我要伸张正义！你懂这个词吗？正义！现在，滚吧。
Essentially, Jackson started over again. He did eventually replace the cabinet.
本质上，杰克逊重新开始了。他最终确实更换了内阁。
Was there any talk at the time that Jackson's obsession with this, that he was a little off-kilter, or he was just crazy? Why is he jeopardizing his entire government over defense of this woman? Or did they see it as, well, we've got to get our loyalties straight or we can't function as a government anyway, so this is sort of part of the purging? It seems crazy.
当时有人说杰克逊对此的着魔有点不正常，或者他只是疯了？他为什么要为了保卫这个女人而危及他的整个政府？或者他们认为，好吧，我们必须理清我们的忠诚关系，否则我们无论如何都无法作为政府运作，所以这算是清洗的一部分？这看起来很疯狂。
Yes. I don't think there was the same level of awareness. It's the historians who've gone back and looked at the amount of time, the number of letters that he wrote, that in retrospect, it's clear how obsessional he became about this. At the time, I think it was seen more as, this is partisan politics, and that it was viewed as a faction war.
是的。我不认为当时有同样的意识水平。是历史学家们回过头来看他花费的时间，他写的信件的数量，回想起来，很明显他变得多么着魔。当时，我认为这更多地被视为一种党派政治，并且被视为一场派系战争。
American politics was in transition, Nancy says, from a party system that was more elite-dominated to a party system where the vast majority of white men could vote, whether or not they owned property or were well-educated. Politicians who want to get elected need to do this new thing-- engage the masses. Engage their base. And they found-- then, as now-- that these kinds of moral issues engaged the base.
南希说，美国政治正处于过渡时期，从一个更受精英支配的政党体系到一个绝大多数白人男性都可以投票的政党体系，无论他们是否拥有财产或受过良好教育。想要当选的政治家需要做这件新事——参与群众。吸引他们的基本盘。而他们发现——当时正如现在——这些道德问题能吸引基本盘。
In fact, at the time, it was seen as an issue of the elite Eastern seaboard against the up-and-coming West. It was the common man against the aristocrats. Peggy was a woman of the people. Andrew Jackson was a man of the people. To focus on this kind of trivia, this gossip, to allow the gossip of these Washington matrons to trouble the president was a sign of this elite aristocracy creeping in.
事实上，当时它被视为精英东海岸与正在崛起的西部之间的问题。这是普通人对抗贵族。佩吉是人民的女性。安德鲁·杰克逊是人民的男人。关注这类琐事、这种流言，允许这些华盛顿贵妇的流言困扰总统，是这种精英贵族阶层渗透进来的标志。
And that was completely unacceptable in the new republic. It had to be rooted out. Jackson himself, he saw this as a conspiracy on the part of the Adams party to destroy him. And thus, by defending Peggy Eaton, he's really defending himself.
而这在新的共和国是完全不可接受的。它必须被根除。杰克逊本人认为这是亚当斯党阴谋摧毁他的一部分。因此，通过保卫佩吉·伊顿，他实际上是在保卫自己。
The person he's largely defending himself against is his own vice president, John Calhoun. Remember, it's Calhoun's wife, Floride, who led the society women against Peggy. John Calhoun and Jackson were fighting about other things, too, not just Peggy.
他主要防御的对象是他自己的副总统约翰·卡尔霍恩。记住，是卡尔霍恩的妻子弗洛里德领导社交界的女士们对抗佩吉。约翰·卡尔霍恩和杰克逊也在为其他事情争斗，不仅仅是佩吉。
A hugely controversial tariff, for instance, in 1828. It's a tariff on imported goods that Southerners like Calhoun see as putting the South, and especially his home state of South Carolina, at a disadvantage to the benefit of Northern manufacturers. And as their personal fight over Peggy Eaton spirals out of control, as Calhoun gets increasingly angry at Jackson, he starts agitating for the right of South Carolina to protect its own interests, even to secede, if necessary.
例如，1828年极具争议的关税。这是对进口商品征收的关税，南方人像卡尔霍恩认为这使南方，特别是他的家乡南卡罗来纳州处于劣势，而受益的是北方制造商。随着他们关于佩吉·伊顿的个人争斗失控，随着卡尔霍恩对杰克逊越来越愤怒，他开始煽动南卡罗来纳州保护自身利益的权利，如果有必要，甚至要分裂。
Then South Carolina tries to openly defy federal law. In 1832, it declares that federal tariffs will be null and void within its borders. It's the Nullification Crisis. It's one of the biggest challenges of Jackson's presidency. That same year, Vice President John Calhoun quits.
然后南卡罗来纳州试图公开蔑视联邦法律。1832年，它宣布联邦关税在其境内无效。这就是“废止危机”。这是杰克逊总统任期内最大的挑战之一。同年，副总统约翰·卡尔霍恩辞职。
Calhoun, once he resigns, he goes back to South Carolina. He's elected to the Senate, and as a senator, becomes the architect of the states' rights philosophy in the South. Jackson, as a Southerner, is sympathetic to states' rights. But when push comes to shove, he sees the Union as the top priority and faces down Calhoun in the Nullification Controversy.
卡尔霍恩辞职后回到了南卡罗来纳州。他当选为参议员，并作为参议员成为了南方各州权利哲学的设计师。杰克逊作为南方人，对各州权利持同情态度。但当事情到了紧要关头，他视联邦为最高优先级，并在废止论争中对抗卡尔霍恩。
It's a major, major rehearsal for the Civil War. They eventually reach a compromise, so South Carolina does not secede. But Abraham Lincoln took a great deal of inspiration from Andrew Jackson's position. The Union-above-all position that Lincoln would eventually have to adopt, as well.
这是内战的一次重大预演。他们最终达成了妥协，因此南卡罗来纳州没有分裂。但亚伯拉罕·林肯从安德鲁·杰克逊的立场中获得了极大的启发。这也是林肯最终不得不采取的“联邦至上”立场。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
So Peggy Eaton saved the Union.
所以佩吉·伊顿拯救了联邦。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Yes, Peggy really gave us the red, white and blue, and--
是的，佩吉真的给了我们红、白、蓝三色旗，而且——
That's why you and I are sitting here today.
这就是为什么你和我今天能坐在这里。
That's right.
没错。
The big winner in all this-- besides the Union, of course, and Joan Crawford-- was a man whose name has undoubtedly been on the tip of your tongue-- Martin Van Buren. He became the next vice president, and after that, the next president. Not John Calhoun, who'd been widely expected to take over. Once he resigned as vice president, Calhoun's aspirations were finished.
在这场斗争中的大赢家——除了联邦，当然，还有琼·克劳馥——是一个名字无疑在你的舌尖上的男人——马丁·范布伦。他成为了下一任副总统，并在那之后成为了下一任总统。不是被广泛预期会接任的约翰·卡尔霍恩。一旦他辞去副总统职务，卡尔霍恩的抱负就结束了。
No, it was Van Buren, the only member of Jackson's cabinet who'd carefully, strategically supported Peggy Eaton during the Petticoat Affair, who understood that it was in his own interest to break Washington social protocol and pay a visit to Mrs. Eaton. To knock on her door.
不，是范布伦，他是杰克逊内阁中唯一一个在“衬裙事件”期间谨慎、战略性地支持佩吉·伊顿的成员，他明白打破华盛顿社交礼仪并拜访伊顿夫人符合他自己的利益。去敲她的门。
30 years after the Petticoat Affair, in 1860, a journalist named James Parton published a biography of Jackson. Chapter 23 was titled "Mr. Van Buren Calls On Mrs. Eaton." Parton wrote, quote, "The political history of the United States for the last 30 years dates from the moment when the soft hand of Mr. Van Buren touched Mrs. Eaton's knocker."
“衬裙事件”30年后，1860年，一位名叫詹姆斯·帕顿的记者出版了一本杰克逊的传记。第23章标题是“范布伦先生拜访伊顿夫人”。帕顿写道，引用：“美国过去30年的政治史，从范布伦先生那柔软的手触碰到伊顿夫人的门环的那一刻起。”
Sarah Koenig. I don't know what you just think you heard right there, but she is one of the producers of our show.
萨拉·凯尼格。我不知道你刚才认为你听到了什么，但她是我们要节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "PEGGY O'NEIL" BY TONY WILLIAMS]
[音乐 - 托尼·威廉姆斯的“佩吉·奥尼尔”]
Coming up, a teenager tries to understand why her dad wants to adopt a 27-year-old ex-con into the family. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一个十几岁的女孩试图理解为什么她父亲想收养一个27岁的前罪犯进入家庭。请稍候，芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目即将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, "Surrogates." People standing in for other people, substituting in all kinds of situations. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, "Maul in the Family."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们都会选择一个主题，带给你关于这个主题的不同故事。今天的节目是“替身”。人们在各种情况下为他人代行。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“家庭狂暴”。
This is a story where a bunch of people, including the father of the person who's going to be telling the story, see themselves in somebody who did some truly, truly awful things. A warning-- if you're listening with kids or have sensitivity to such things, this story has some violence in it. On the positive side, there's also a brief appearance by Neil Patrick Harris. Amity Bitzel tells the story.
这是一个故事，包括讲述这个故事的人的父亲在内的一群人，在某个做了些真正极其可怕事情的人身上看到了自己的影子。警告——如果你和孩子们一起收听或者对这类事情比较敏感，这个故事包含一些暴力内容。从积极的一面来看，尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯也有短暂的露面。阿米蒂·比策尔讲述这个故事。
When I was 16, my parents adopted a 27-year-old man. Not long after he moved in, NBC broadcast a made-for-TV movie based on his life called Sudden Fury-- A Family Torn Apart. It was about his life before we adopted him.
16岁时，我的父母收养了一个27岁的男人。他搬进来不久，NBC就播出了一部基于他生活的电视电影，名为《突如其来的狂暴——一个破碎的家庭》。讲的是我们收养他之前的生活。
My entire family gathered in our living room to watch. Neil Patrick Harris played the character based on my new brother. It opens with him, a teenager in a big suburban house, making a phone call.
我们全家人聚在客厅里观看。尼尔·帕特里克·哈里斯饰演基于我新哥哥的角色。电影以他开始，一个住在大郊区房子的少年，正在打电话。
[PHONE BEING DIALED]
[电话拨号声]
Annapolis Police. Hello? I'm sorry, I can't hear you.
安纳波利斯警察局。喂？抱歉，我听不见你说什么。
I think my parents are dead.
我想我的父母死了。
When the police arrive at the house, it's a gruesome scene. His father is in the basement, covered with blood, stabbed to death. His mother's outside in her pajamas, lying face-down in the yard. She's been both stabbed and bludgeoned.
当警察赶到屋子时，那是令人毛骨悚然的场景。他父亲在地下室，满身是血，被捅死了。他母亲在外面穿着睡衣，脸朝下躺在院子里。她既被捅伤又被殴打致死。
In the movie, they call my adopted brother Brian, though his name was really Larry Swartz. And in the film, as he becomes the main suspect, his lawyers confront him.
在电影里，他们叫我收养的哥哥布莱恩，尽管他的名字实际上是拉里·斯瓦茨。在电影中，随着他成为主要嫌疑人，他的律师与他对质。
Listen, Brian, we have a little problem. The police don't believe your story. They think you're lying. Like how you got blood on your shoes, and why you didn't hear anything on the night of the murder. How do you explain that?
听着，布莱恩，我们有个小麻烦。警察不相信你的故事。他们认为你在撒谎。比如你的鞋子上怎么会有血，为什么你在谋杀当晚什么都没听到。你怎么解释？
I can't.
我没法解释。
Yes you can. Yes, you can.
你能的。你能的。
I can't.
我没法解释。
Tell me what happened.
告诉我发生了什么。
I can't. [SCREAMS WITH RAGE]
我没法解释。[狂怒的尖叫]
[SOBS]
[抽泣]
[SCREAMS WITH RAGE]
[狂怒的尖叫]
He wouldn't stop hurting me. He wouldn't stop hurting me. He wouldn't stop.
他没完没了地伤害我。他没完没了地伤害我。他没完没了。
My sister and I sat on the floor as the film played. Larry, the real person, my new brother, who killed his parents, sat next to my mom and dad, his new mom and dad, on the couch. Everyone acted calm.
电影播放时，我和姐姐坐在地板上。拉里，那个真人，我新哥哥，那个杀了他父母的人，坐在沙发上，挨着我的爸爸妈妈，他新的爸爸妈妈。每个人看起来都很平静。
[WEEPING]
[哭泣]
The movie did a pretty good job of portraying what actually happened. A warning-- this next half-minute or so of my story gets graphic. He'd repeatedly stabbed his father and his mother with a kitchen knife and bludgeoned his mother with a maul, one of those big wood-chopping things that looks like an axe. The movie doesn't include this, but when the police found Larry's mother's body, she was naked. Larry's lawyer told a reporter that Larry admitted to sexually violating her.
这部电影在描绘实际发生的事情方面做得相当不错。警告——我故事的接下来的半分钟左右会有些生动描写。他用一把厨房刀反复捅死了父亲和母亲，并用一个槌子——那种看起来像斧头的大木头切割工具——殴打了他母亲。电影里没包含这个，但当警察发现拉里母亲的尸体时，她是赤裸的。拉里的律师告诉记者，拉里承认曾对她进行过性侵犯。
When the end credits rolled, we agreed the movie seemed over the top, almost corny, in that prime-time TV way. I remember somebody-- either Larry or my dad-- joking about how melodramatic it all was. It was a hallucinatory experience, but also it was somehow utterly banal. Let's watch a movie about our adopted killer brother, joke about it, and then get ready for bed.
当片尾字幕滚动时，我们一致认为这部电影显得太夸张了，甚至有些陈腐，那种黄金时段电视的风格。我记得有人——要么是拉里要么是我爸——开玩笑说它有多么戏剧化。这是一种幻觉般的体验，但同时也以某种方式显得极其平庸。让我们看一部关于我们收养的杀手哥哥的电影，拿它开玩笑，然后准备睡觉。
Larry ended up in our family because about four years earlier, my mother read the book the film was based on, Sudden Fury , by a reporter named Leslie Walker, and gave it to my dad, who read it also. Which was weird, because he rarely read anything. He was never enthusiastic about a book.
拉里最终进入我们家是因为大约四年前，我母亲读了这部电影所基于的书，《突如其来的狂暴》，由一位名叫莱斯利·沃克的记者撰写，并把它给了我爸爸，他也读了。这很奇怪，因为他很少读书。他从未对一本书表现出热情。
But he seemed to really connect with the story. And when my parents talked about the case and Larry, they didn't say, oh, who could do such a violent and horrible thing? They said how sorry they felt for him, how he was a victim of abuse. Which he was.
但他似乎真的与这个故事产生了共鸣。当我的父母谈论这个案子和拉里时，他们没有说，噢，谁会做出如此暴力和可怕的事情？他们说他们对他感到多么抱歉，他是虐待的受害者。他确实是。
The book details Larry's troubled childhood, starting with how his mother abandoned him as a toddler, and follows him as he's shuttled through an uncaring foster system, six families in all. One foster mother broke his arm. In several homes, Larry showed signs of an eating disorder, even sneaking food out of garbage cans.
这本书详细描述了拉里坎坷的童年，从他母亲在蹒跚学步时如何抛弃他开始，并跟随他穿梭于一个冷漠的寄养系统中，总共六个家庭。一位寄养母亲打断了他的胳膊。在几个家庭里，拉里表现出了饮食失调的迹象，甚至从垃圾桶里偷吃东西。
Larry's adoption by the well-meaning Swartzes was meant to give him the family he had longed for. But as time went on, the Swartzes became controlling and emotionally abusive.
好心的斯瓦茨夫妇收养拉里本来是为了给他他所渴望的家庭。但随着时间的推移，斯瓦茨夫妇变得具有控制欲并且在情感上进行虐待。
After he read Sudden Fury , my dad wrote a letter to Larry in prison. And for whatever reason, Larry wrote back to my dad. Letters graduated to phone calls, and eventually, my father began driving several hours away to visit with Larry.
读完《突如其来的狂暴》后，我爸爸给监狱里的拉里写了一封信。出于某种原因，拉里给爸爸回了信。信件演变成了电话，最终，父亲开始开车几个小时去监狱探望拉里。
The next thing I knew, my dad told us that we were going to visit Larry together in prison as a family. He wants to meet you guys, my dad told us.
接下来我知道的就是，爸爸告诉我们全家要一起去监狱探望拉里。爸爸告诉我们，他想见见你们。
We were let into the visiting room. I noticed the other people sitting there and wondered if they were seeing murderers, too. And then, suddenly, there was Larry. He and my dad hugged, and then my dad pushed me to hug him as well. I didn't want to, but with my dad, you did what you were told.
我们被带进了探视室。我注意到坐在那里的其他人，纳闷他们是不是也来看杀人犯的。然后，突然，拉里出现了。他和爸爸拥抱，然后爸爸推我我也去拥抱他。我不想，但爸爸的话你必须听。
I knew what Larry looked like from pictures in the book. Here, he looked normal, unassuming. Slight build, big, dark eyes with almost girlish lashes, soft-spoken.
我从书中的照片里知道拉里长什么样。在这里，他看起来很正常，不显眼。瘦削的体格，大大的黑眼睛，睫毛几乎像女孩一样，说话轻声细语。
We'd brought Big Macs and fries, and we sat there picking at food awkwardly. I don't think it could've been any more awkward. My little sister asked Larry if he had seen the movie Mermaids , with Cher. We talked about what the weather was going to do. How do you girls like school?
我们带了巨无霸和薯条，坐在那里笨拙地吃着。我不觉得还能有什么比这更尴尬的了。我的小妹妹问拉里是否看过雪儿主演的电影《风情妈咪俏女儿》。我们谈论天气会怎么样。你们女孩喜欢学校吗？
The thought that was running through my head during this prison visit, that had been running through my head ever since I'd first heard my parents talk about Larry, was this. How could my parents feel so sorry for Larry and his terrible circumstances? Why didn't they feel sorry for me?
在那次探监过程中，我脑子里一直闪过的念头，也就是自从我第一次听到父母谈论拉里以来就一直在脑子里闪过的念头，就是这个。我父母怎么能对拉里和他可怕的环境感到如此同情？为什么他们不对我感到同情？
Because life with my father was miserable. In my house, we lived by his rules, rules that were fluid and shifting and terrifying. Something small and accidental could set him off in a rage. Maybe my sister or I broke a cup or slammed the car door too hard. Or maybe we hadn't even done anything at all. We would still be on the receiving end of my father's wrath. And once he started drinking, we knew we were in for it.
因为和我父亲住在一起是悲惨的。在我的家里，我们遵守他的规则，这些规则是变动不居且令人恐惧的。一件小事或偶然的差错就能让他狂怒。也许我和姐姐打破了一个杯子，或者用力关了车门。或者也许我们什么都没做。我们仍然会受到父亲愤怒的攻击。而一旦他开始喝酒，我们就知道我们要遭殃了。
These episodes usually began the same way. First, he would drink. Not even hard alcohol, just beer. And he would blast music and sing loudly, always Jackson Browne and John Cougar Mellencamp. To this day, I have a visceral Pavlovian response to songs like "Running on Empty."
这些插曲通常以同样的方式开始。首先，他会喝酒。甚至不是烈酒，只是啤酒。然后他会大声播放音乐并高声歌唱，总是杰克逊·布朗和约翰·库格·梅伦坎普的歌。直到今天，我对像《Running on Empty》这样的歌还有一种本能的巴甫洛夫反应。
Then after his low-grade anger progressed into full-blown fury, he might force us all into the family van and drive us around drunk for hours, screaming and swerving the whole time. Or he might go into my sister's room and smash up every piece of furniture in it. He might brandish a rifle and threaten to shoot all of us. He might hit me or my sister with a belt. Worst of all, he might wrap his hands around my mother's throat and strangle her as my sister and I tried to pull him away.
然后，当他低强度的愤怒升级为全面狂暴后，他可能会强迫我们全家挤进家庭面包车，酒后开车带我们在外面转几个小时，一路尖叫和横冲直撞。或者他可能会走进我姐姐的房间，砸碎里面的每一件家具。他可能会挥舞步枪威胁要枪杀我们所有人。他可能会用皮带抽打我和姐姐。最糟糕的是，他可能会双手扼住我母亲的喉咙，当我和姐姐试图把他拉开时，他会试图勒死她。
I don't know why it never occurred to me to call the police during any of this, but I never did. No one did. And things weren't at this level all the time, of course. Even on a good day, though, it felt like living in a child's version of war, just waiting to see if the bombs would start falling and wishing you had shelter.
我不知道为什么在这些过程中我从未想过要报警，但我从来没报过。没有人报过。当然，事情并不总是达到这种程度。但即使是在美好的一天，感觉也像是生活在儿童版的战争中，只是等着看炸弹会不会掉下来，并希望你有避难所。
By 1993, Larry was set to be released. He'd originally had a 12-year sentence, but three years of that were knocked off for good behavior. The judge could have given him two 20-year sentences for both of the murders, but knocked it down to 12 years total, which shows how seriously the judicial system viewed Larry's troubled upbringing. In the end, he served nine years.
到1993年，拉里定于获释。他最初被判了12年刑期，但其中三年因为表现良好被减免了。法官本可以因两起谋杀案判他两个20年，但减到了总共12年，这表明司法系统对他坎坷的成长经历看得有多严重。最后，他服刑了九年。
For a while, my parents had been talking about how Larry would have no place to live and nowhere to go. He would be on probation, and he would need a job. My dad was worried that Larry would be eaten up on the outside, that he needed guidance.
有一段时间，我的父母一直在讨论拉里将无处居住，无处可去。他会处于缓刑期，而且需要一份工作。爸爸担心拉里在外面会被人吃掉，他需要引导。
How would he be able to forge a life for himself, especially bearing that notorious name that had been on the news? The name of a convicted murderer? And so the decision was made that Larry would be formally adopted into our family. He would take our last name, and he would live with us in our home.
他怎么可能为自己创造生活，尤其是背负那个曾在新闻上出现过的臭名昭著的名字？一个被定罪的杀人犯的名字？所以决定做出了，拉里将正式被收养进我们的家庭。他会改我们的姓，他会和我们住在一起。
There was never a big discussion about any of this. As with everything else, we were informed of the new plan by my dad after it had already been decided. I don't remember my mom saying much about it. That was how she was about almost everything, a silent bystander. It's the right thing to do, Dad said, and so that was that.
这一切从来没有过深入讨论。和其他事情一样，我们是在计划已经决定后才被爸爸通知的。我不记得妈妈对此说过什么。她对几乎所有事情都是这样，一个沉默的旁观者。“这是该做的事，”爸爸说，事情就这么定了。
But it didn't mean I was OK with it. I'd gotten used to meeting with Larry in prison, but the idea of him sleeping in the bedroom next to mine? That was a whole different proposition.
但这并不意味着我对此没意见。我已经习惯了在监狱里见拉里，但让他睡在我的隔壁房间？那是完全不同的事情。
I had fantasies where some responsible adult would find out and say, oh my God, we have to stop this. I remember telling one of my girlfriends the entire story. She was shocked, of course, though she knew what my dad was like. But when she told her mother what my family was doing, her mother said, well, that's a very Christian thing to do. The outside world was never coming to intervene, to save any of us.
我曾幻想有负责任的成年人发现并说，噢上帝，我们必须阻止这一切。我记得我把整个故事告诉了我的一位女朋友。她当然很震惊，尽管她知道我爸爸是什么样的人。但当她告诉她母亲我们家在做什么时，她母亲说，嗯，那是一件非常有基督精神的事情。外部世界永远不会介入，来拯救我们中的任何人。
On Larry's first night in our home, we had dinner. There was a celebratory cake. The only way to get through this, really, was to disassociate, a skill I all too familiar with. I tried not to think at all. Chew, swallow, smile.
拉里在我们家里的第一晚，我们吃了晚饭。有一个庆祝蛋糕。度过这一关的唯一方法，真的，就是解离，一种我非常熟悉的技巧。我尽量什么都不想。咀嚼，吞咽，微笑。
And Larry was not scary or menacing. Not at all. He was nice and funny. I never had any fear that he would hurt me, or any of us. It wasn't hard to forget what he had done, because he didn't seem to be thinking about it, ever.
拉里既不可怕也不具威胁性。一点也不。他很友好，也很风趣。我从未担心他会伤害我或我们中的任何一个人。要忘记他所做的事情并不难，因为他似乎从不考虑它。
He actually took me to the mall that first week. Neither one of us had a license, and we got lost on the way. But contrary to what my dad would have done, which is freak out and start screaming and berating me, Larry just laughed and got us going in the right direction. We didn't have a lot to talk about, just chatted about movies and music. When we got there, he bought me my first pair of Doc Martens.
那第一周他甚至带我去了购物中心。我们俩都没有驾照，路上迷路了。但与爸爸会做的相反——爸爸会抓狂并开始尖叫和责骂我——拉里只是笑了笑，带我们朝着正确的方向前进。我们没什么话可说，只是聊聊电影和音乐。当我们到达那里时，他给我买了我人生中第一双马丁靴。
Looking back, what's most striking to me is that Larry, the man who had stabbed and bludgeoned his parents to death, wasn't nearly as scary to me as my own father.
回顾过去，最让我印象深刻的是拉里，那个捅死并用槌子敲死他父母的男人，在我眼里远没有我的父亲那么可怕。
Larry settled in, made friends, went out drinking. Mind-blowingly to me, he even started to date. And Larry's presence brought us a truly unexpected benefit. As he settled into his new life in our house, things actually seemed to get calmer in our family.
拉里安定了下来，结交了朋友，出去喝酒。让我大吃一惊的是，他甚至开始约会。而拉里的出现给我们带来了一个真正意想不到的好处。随着他在我们家安定下来，家里似乎真的变平静了。
Incredibly, my father stopped much of his old behavior. You could spill a drink at the dinner table and not have to cringe in fearful anticipation. It was like the outside-world father, the one that smiled and was kind and funny in public, had somehow become the inside-world father.
令人难以置信的是，父亲停止了许多他旧有的行为。你可以在餐桌上洒出饮料而不需要畏缩着等待恐惧的来临。这就像那个外部世界的父亲，那个在公共场合微笑、友善又风趣的人，不知怎地变成了家庭内部的父亲。
My dad was good to Larry. He got him a job. They went out together a lot, saying they were going fishing, going to a bar. They grocery shopped together sometimes. There was rough-housing and laughter.
爸爸对拉里很好。他给他找了份工作。他们经常一起出去，说他们要去钓鱼、去酒吧。他们有时一起去杂货店买东西。有打闹和笑声。
My dad even had an addition built onto our house for Larry so that everyone would have more room. Eventually, though, my dad decided that our house still wasn't big enough and that we would have to get a bigger, nicer house. So we moved. That year, even though we had never been on a true family vacation together pre-Larry, my parents took everyone to Disney World, although I said I had too much schoolwork and didn't go with them.
爸爸甚至在我们的房子上为拉里加盖了一个房间，这样每个人都有更多的空间。然而最终，爸爸决定我们的房子还是不够大，我们得买一栋更大、更好的房子。于是我们搬了家。那一年，尽管拉里到来之前我们从未真正全家一起度假过，父母还是带了所有人去迪斯尼世界，虽然我说我有太多的作业没去。
I'm not sure if Larry ever knew the father I knew, if he suspected the loving family that took him in echoed in any way the abusive homes he had lived in growing up.
我不确定拉里是否曾经知道我所了解的那个父亲，他不确定那个收养他的充满爱的家庭是否在某种程度上回荡着他成长过程中经历过的那些虐待家庭。
Larry is dead now. He eventually got married and moved to Florida, and then died of a heart attack there in his late 30s. And 20 years after Larry became my brother, I'm still wondering why. For years, my sister and I maintained a polite facade with our parents, never bringing up the abuse and barely discussing Larry. So much time had gone by, maybe it was best to just forgive and forget as much as possible.
拉里现在去世了。他最终结婚并搬到了佛罗里达，然后在那里30多岁时死于心脏病发作。在拉里成为我哥哥20年后，我仍然在纳闷为什么。多年来，我和姐姐与父母保持着礼貌的面具，从不提及虐待，几乎不讨论拉里。时间过得太久了，也许最好的办法就是尽可能地宽恕和遗忘。
But in the last 12 months, my sister and I have gotten closer, and we finally started to talk honestly about the past. We wondered what would happen if we stopped speaking to our dad completely. Would that make us horrible people? Evil and cruel daughters, like some reverse fairytale? Together, we decided to cut off contact.
但在过去12个月里，我和姐姐的关系近了，我们终于开始诚实地谈论过去。我们纳闷如果我们完全不跟爸爸说话会发生什么。那会让我们成为可怕的人吗？像某些反童话故事里的邪恶残忍的女儿？我们决定一起断绝联系。
We each did this over email. Mine wasn't overly dramatic or vitriolic. Just a short note explaining that I needed to stop talking to him because of all the things he had done. He sent lots of emails after I sent mine, and I read them all without responding. I'm not sure how I'm supposed to navigate this, how this new stage works. And I still have so many questions for him. There are lots of things that only he has the answer to.
我们都是通过电子邮件做到这一点的。我的邮件并不太戏剧化或尖酸刻薄。只是简短说明我需要停止和他说话，因为他所做的一切事情。在我发出邮件后，他发了很多封邮件，我全读了但没回复。我不确定我该如何应对这个阶段，不知道这个新阶段如何运作。而且我仍然对他有很多疑问。有很多事情只有他才有答案。
As I was working on this story, I was still too scared to ask him about Larry myself. Just the thought of asking him anything about the past seemed frightening. So the producer from This American Life I've been working with on this story, Brian Reed, offered to do it for me. So Brian talked to him in the studio.
当我在写这个故事时，我还是太害怕亲自问他关于拉里的事。仅仅是想到问他关于过去的任何事情似乎都很可怕。所以我一直合作的一位《美国生活》的制作人布莱恩·里德主动提议帮我。所以布莱恩在演播室里和他谈了谈。
Hi, Brian, how you doing?
嗨，布莱恩，你好吗？
Hi, Glenn. How are you?
嗨，格伦。你好吗？
Good, good.
挺好，挺好。
They talked for two hours-- about Larry, about how the book was the catalyst for everything my dad did for him, about the big question, why he adopted Larry. He said at one point he had to explain to a judge exactly that.
他们聊了两个小时——关于拉里，关于那本书如何成为爸爸为他所做一切的催化剂，关于那个大问题，他为什么收养拉里。他说在某个时刻他不得不向法官解释清楚这一点。
The judge looked at me square in the eye, which a lot of the questions he had, I'm sure, are the same questions that everyone else had. Why are you involved in this? And I just looked at him and said, everybody needs a family.
法官直视着我的眼睛，我相信他有的很多疑问和每个人的一样。你为什么要卷入这件事？我只是看着他说，每个人都需要一个家庭。
And that's really the only thing that I can comment on, as far as why. Everybody needs a family, and certainly, this is one young man, as an adult, who never really had a childhood, who needs a family. Especially when he gets out.
这就是我能评论的关于原因的唯一事情。每个人都需要一个家庭，当然，作为一个成年人，这是一个从未真正拥有童年、需要家庭的年轻人。尤其是在他出来之后。
Now, so I need to ask you this, just because I read the book, recently, Sudden Fury . And you know, you talking about Larry, you said several times, "poor old Larry." And you clearly love him and are very sympathetic towards him.
现在，我需要问你这个，仅仅是因为我最近读了那本书，《突如其来的狂暴》。你知道，你在谈论拉里时，好几次说“可怜的老拉里”。你显然爱他，而且对他非常同情。
But when I read that book, I mean, I have some sympathy for him, for sure. He had a very challenging childhood that I find hard to imagine. But I also see a person who brutally stabbed his parents, hit his mother over the head with a maul and sexually violated her.
但当我读那本书时，我的意思是，我肯定对他有一点同情。他有一个非常艰难的童年，这让我很难想象。但我同时也看到了一个残忍地捅死他父母、用槌子敲他母亲的头并性侵犯她的男人。
And so I find it very hard to think of him as "poor old Larry." And I wonder, what did you identify with personally in that story? I mean, to the point where you--
所以我发现很难把他看作“可怜的老拉里”。我纳闷，你个人在这个故事中认同什么？我的意思是，达到你——
Abuse.
虐待。
I mean, it's one thing to read the book--
我的意思是，读那本书是一回事——
Abuse. Parental abuse, obviously. I didn't want to go back into my childhood too far, but that's-- you know, it's, that's a whole--
虐待。父母虐待，显然。我不想回想我的童年太多，但那是——你知道，这，这是一个整体——
What can you say about it, to help people understand? What would--
关于它你有什么能说的，来帮助人们理解？会——
Physical, mental-- physical, mental, emotional, you name it. I lost my mother at age eight. And I'm not really sure that my father ever wanted us. So I just identified with him mainly from my experience growing up as a child. Just touched a nerve with me.
身体上的、精神上的——身体上的、精神上的、情感上的，你能想到的都有。我在8岁时失去了母亲。我不确定我的父亲是否想要我们。所以我主要是根据我童年成长的经历与他产生认同。这触动了我的神经。
When we got to talking about different things, about things that happened in certain foster homes, and I-- well, you know what? That happened in my house, too. I never ended up doing the thing that Larry did, but I will say this-- it's not something that never crossed my mind.
当我们谈到不同的事情，关于在某些寄养家庭发生的事情时，我——嗯，你知道吗？那也发生在我家里。我最终没做拉里做的那种事，但我会说这一点——这并不是没在我脑海里闪过过。
You know, I'd wondered that. Do you remember what you thought or when you thought it?
你知道，我一直纳闷那个。你还记得你当时想了什么或者什么时候想的吗？
Mostly when my mom was being beaten. You don't like to watch that day after day, especially when you're five, six years old, seven years old. Another time that I can remember was he would go off for simple little things that made no sense, like a bag of groceries falling off a car seat and the eggs breaking. That happened one day, and we were beaten for it.
主要是妈妈被打的时候。你不想日复一日地看那个，尤其是当你5岁、6岁、7岁时。我记得的另一次是他会因为一些毫无意义的小事发火，比如一袋杂货从车座上掉下来，鸡蛋碎了。有一天发生了这种事，我们因此被毒打。
And my brother took off running, and ran as fast as he could through a field of plowed dirt. And he had his head and his face pushed face-down in it. And that was one time when I just was so angry and so upset that I thought about it.
我哥哥跑掉了，他尽可能快地穿过一片犁过的土地。他的头和脸被推得脸朝下埋进土里。那是我感到如此愤怒和沮丧以至于想到它的一次。
Did you tell Larry that story?
你告诉过拉里那个故事吗？
Sure. Told Larry everything.
当然。什么都告诉拉里了。
What did he say?
他说了什么？
He understood, but he certainly was glad that, you know, that I didn't do it, because I wouldn't have been there to help him, in his kind of jokingly way. He always kept a smile on your face.
他理解，但他当然很高兴，你知道，我没那样做，因为他开玩笑地说，那样就没人帮他了。他总是让你的脸上保持微笑。
Apparently lots of people who had troubled relationships with their parents identified with Larry. The book my dad read about Larry names a few. Larry's lawyer, who was estranged from his own father, and defended Larry pro bono. A 30-year-old mother who talked to Larry on the phone almost every night as he awaited trial-- she lost her mom as a kid and had come very close to shooting her abusive father. Like my dad, each of them seemed to see some version of themselves in Larry.
显然，许多与父母关系不佳的人都认同拉里。我爸爸读的那本关于拉里的书提到了一些人。拉里的律师，他自己就和父亲断绝了关系，并且免费为拉里辩护。一位30岁的母亲，在拉里等待审判期间几乎每晚都在电话里和他交谈——她小时候失去了母亲，曾差点枪杀她虐待的父亲。像我爸爸一样，他们每个人似乎都在拉里身上看到了自己的一些影子。
My dad spoke longingly about Larry. He and my mom live in Florida now, and he told Brian a good part of the reason they moved there was to be close to where Larry died. He said the Larry he knew was not the Larry described in the Sudden Fury book, that years of therapy had worked and he was a different person. He explained how honest Larry was, how generous he was, and how appreciative he was of what my parents did for him.
爸爸深情地谈论着拉里。他和妈妈现在住在佛罗里达，他告诉布莱恩，他们搬到那里很大一部分原因是为了靠近拉里去世的地方。他说他认识的那个拉里不是《突如其来的狂暴》书中描述的拉里，多年来的治疗起作用了，他变成了一个不同的人。他解释了拉里有多诚实，他有多慷慨，以及他对父母为他所做的一切有多感激。
Brian also asked my dad some sensitive questions about how he behaved during my childhood to give him the chance to tell his side of the story. My dad categorically denied that he was abusive when I was growing up. He denied getting drunk and smashing furniture, driving us around and yelling, or strangling my mom. He denied hitting my sister and I with a belt. He denied waving around a rifle and threatening to shoot us all.
布莱恩还问了我爸爸一些关于他在我童年时期表现的敏感问题，让他有机会讲述他那边的故事。我爸爸断然否认我在成长过程中受到虐待。他否认喝醉酒砸坏家具、开车带我们到处转悠并大喊大叫、或者勒死我妈妈。他否认用皮带抽打我和姐姐。他否认挥舞步枪威胁要枪杀我们所有人。
No. Those things never happened. I don't know why she would say those things.
不。那些事从没发生过。我不知道她为什么要说那些事。
Amity had a wonderful childhood. Horseback riding lessons. Amity got in fights in school, I'd go and I'd get them straightened out.
阿米蒂有一个美好的童年。骑马课程。阿米蒂在学校打架，我过去会把事情处理好。
I mean, I was always there for her. There's different levels of abuse, but you're talking about 100% level in my case and a zero in hers.
我的意思是，我总是在她身边。虐待有不同的程度，但在我的案例中，你谈论的是100%的程度，而在她身上是零。
And your case, you mean when you were a kid.
你的情况是指你小时候。
When I was a kid.
当我小时候。
And are you just measuring against what you experienced? Or you think, like, in an objective way--
你是仅仅用你经历过的来衡量？还是你认为，像，以一种客观的方式——
In an objective way, I honestly don't see where there was any abuse at all.
以客观的方式，我真的看不出有任何虐待。
Because part of the reason I'm talking to you, and not her, is because she says she's cut off contact with you. And I wonder, what do you think her reason is for that?
因为我找你谈话的部分原因，而不是她，是因为她说她已经断绝了和你的联系。我纳闷，你认为她那样做的原因是什么？
I just got an email yesterday from her, so that's not true. Saying that she's glad I was going to do this interview, and she wished me good luck.
我昨天才收到她的一封电子邮件，所以这不是真的。她说很高兴我打算参加这次采访，她祝我好运。
She said that she sent you an email maybe six or eight months ago, saying, my sister and I, we aren't going to talk to you guys.
她说她大概六八个月前给你发过一封电子邮件，说，我和姐姐，我们不打算和你们谈了。
No, I've gotten two or three emails from them. Talk to them every Christmas. So she's not feeling any form of animosity or problem, so we're fine. We're all doing fine.
不，我已经收到她们两三封邮件了。每个圣诞节都和她们谈。所以她没有感受到任何形式的敌意或问题，所以我们很好。我们都做得很好。
When you've been through so much abuse as a child, you have to think about, in the back of your mind, too, that you have these things in you that you have to keep tabs on. And you have to keep it under control.
当你小时候经历过如此多的虐待时，你不得不在脑海深处想到，你身上有这些你必须留心的事情。你必须保持控制。
It's very easy for that to be transferred, I think, to your children when they become adults. But Larry was the exact opposite. I mean, after all the abuse, he became one of the better people in the world.
我想，当你的孩子成年后，这种东西很容易被转移给他们。但拉里恰恰相反。我的意思是，经过所有的虐待，他成了世界上最好的人之一。
But that was after-- I mean, he murdered his parents.
但那是在——我的意思是，他杀了他父母。
That's right. That's right. He sure did.
没错。没错。他确实做了。
So how could you say he's one of the better people in the world.
所以你怎能说他是世界上最好的人之一。
He turned out to be, is what I said.
我说的就是，他最终变成了那样。
OK.
好的。
One of the better people in the world. Certainly someone who goes and kills anyone is not a good person, in my book. But at the same time, everyone in that case resolved to the fact that something was wrong. You get to a point, as a child, where you feel like you have nowhere to turn, and by the grace of God, I got through it. And by the grace of God, so did Larry.
世界上最好的人之一。当然，在我的书里，任何去杀人的人都不是好人。但同时，那个案子里的每个人都认定一件事，那就是出了什么问题。作为一个孩子，你到了一个地步，觉得你无处可去，借着上帝的恩典，我撑过去了。借着上帝的恩典，拉里也是。
Obviously, this is really hard for me to listen to. This abuse happened. To me. My sister and a childhood friend who witnessed my dad's behavior both corroborate my memories of him. My sister remembers the same instances of physical abuse.
显然，听这些话对我来说真的很困难。这种虐待发生了。对我。我的姐姐和一位见证过我爸爸行为的童年朋友都证实了我的记忆。我姐姐记得同样的身体虐待事件。
I did send my dad two brief emails to set up this interview with Brian and one right before the interview to decline a check he and my mom had sent me for Christmas. But we did not talk over Christmas. We are not in any kind of regular contact, and we are not, in my or my sister's opinion, doing fine.
我确实发给爸爸两封简短的邮件来安排这次与布莱恩的采访，在采访前一封是拒绝他们寄给我的圣诞支票。但我们圣诞节没谈话。我们没有任何形式的定期联系，在我们或者我姐姐看来，我们并不做得很好。
What's perhaps most horrifying is this. So many of the comments my dad makes about what it's like to see your mother be hurt every day, or feeling you have nowhere to turn, I mean, word for word could have easily come out of my own mouth.
也许最令人震惊的是这一点。我爸爸对每天看着母亲受到伤害是什么感觉，或者感觉无处可去的评论中，有这么多，我的意思是，逐字逐句都可以很容易地出自我的口中。
There's a story my father says he doesn't remember from when I was 10. He was beating and choking my mother in the bathroom, and I couldn't take it anymore. I grabbed a pair of barber sisters, ran up behind him, and literally stabbed him in the back between his shoulder blades. The scissors just stuck there, embedded in the muscle.
有个我爸爸说他不记得的故事，我10岁时发生的。他在浴室里殴打并勒死我母亲，我再也受不了了。我抓起一把理发剪，跑到他身后，从肩膀之间狠狠地刺进了他的背部。剪刀就这样插在那里，嵌入了肌肉。
He threw me off him, and at least for the time being, he left my mom alone. It wasn't a life-threatening wound or anything. I wasn't thinking that I wanted to kill him. But I do remember the intense fear I felt for my mom, and that I just wanted him to stop. And I was willing to stab him to make that happen.
他把我甩开，至少在那时，他没有再管我妈了。那不是致命伤之类的。我当时没想过我想杀他。但我确实记得我对妈妈感到强烈的恐惧，我只是想让他停下来。我愿意刺他来让那件事发生。
My dad's conversation with Brian did help shed light on some things for me. I always thought my dad's reason for adopting Larry, even if it was a subconscious one, was a misguided attempt to start over with a new family member, to right the wrongs he had done us. But after hearing the interview, I think my dad's motivation to adopt Larry was much more about his relationship to his dad than it ever was about his relationship to me, my sister, or my mother.
爸爸与布莱恩的谈话确实为我阐明了一些事情。我一直认为爸爸收养拉里的原因，即使是潜意识的，也是为了重组一个新家庭成员而进行的误导性尝试，来弥补他对我们所做的错误。但在听到采访后，我认为爸爸收养拉里的动力更多地是关于他与他父亲的关系，而不是他与我、我姐姐或我母亲的关系。
A few months ago, I got an email from my father that I'm still not sure what to make of. Sometimes when I read it, it breaks my heart, and other times, it makes me incredibly angry. It feels manipulative. He sent it to both my sister and me.
几个月前，我收到爸爸发来的一封我至今不知道该怎么处理的电子邮件。有时我读它时，心碎不已，而有时，它让我极其愤怒。它感觉具有操控性。他把它发给了我和姐姐。
"My girls," it started. "I want to tell you a story that I hope you will both think about hard and maybe take to heart." He went on to describe, in really frightening detail, the same story he mentioned to Brian about the day he and his brother broke some eggs and his father beat them for it. Then he got to his point.
“我的女孩们，”它开头写道。“我想讲一个故事，希望你们都能好好想想，或许把它记在心里。”他继续以非常令人恐惧的细节描述了同样的事情，就是他提到过给布莱恩的那天，他和哥哥打破了一些鸡蛋而他父亲为此毒打他们的故事。然后他到了他的重点。
"Even though I have not forgotten all the things he did to us, I overcame my bitterness of him and soon became to even love him. I had sworn I would never see my father again after I grew up, but was able to carry on and be decent when he was around. Being able to leave the bitterness behind was my greatest accomplishment, even though I do not have many. I'm here to tell you that things that I did were bad to you both. I regret and feel guilty all the time for being a bad father."
“虽然我没有忘记他对我做的一切，但我克服了对他怨恨，很快甚至开始爱他。我曾发誓长大后永远不再见我父亲，但在他在场时，我能够继续过活并表现得体。能够抛开怨恨是我最大的成就，虽然我没什么成就。我在这里告诉你们，我所做的事情对你们俩都很坏。我一直为作为一个坏父亲感到后悔和愧疚。”
He said that at the least, we should visit with Mom. "Miss you both very much," he wrote. "Love, Dad."
他说至少我们应该去看看妈妈。“非常想念你们，”他写道。“爱你们，爸爸。”
Amity Bitzel. She's writing a memoir, for which she's looking for a publisher.
阿米蒂·比策尔。她正在写一部回忆录，正在寻找出版商。
[MUSIC - "SOMEDAY NEVER COMES" BY CREEDENCE CLEARWATER REVIVAL]
[音乐 - 克里登斯清水复兴合唱团的“Someday Never Comes”]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Lauren Markham produced our story about the twin principals at the opening of the show.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦尔制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、萨拉·凯尼格、美木·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。劳伦·马克姆制作了节目开头关于双胞胎校长的故事。
Production help today from Phia Bennin. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Gettis.
今天的制作协助来自菲亚·贝宁。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。音乐协助来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖蒂斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who has this coverage of the Senate hearings this week with Hillary Clinton.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他本周对希拉里·克林顿的参议院听证会进行了报道。
Shut up. No, you shut up. No, you're ugly. No, you're ugly.
闭嘴。不，你闭嘴。不，你真丑。不，你才丑。
OK. Can we do another? WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains why he has decided that he's going to end his very, very short affair with Lady Gaga.
好的。我们可以再来一遍吗？WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他解释了他为什么决定要结束他与Lady Gaga那非常、非常短暂的恋情。
I gotta walk home with her. I gotta see her when I wake up, when I go to sleep. And I don't like her.
我得和她一起走路回家。我醒来时要见到她，睡觉时也要见到她。而且我不喜欢她。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。